yes shortage shot a little bit sorry
like that swing though Trevor yeah that
looked like the best swing so far today
stayed in ease posture a little bit
better
[Applause]
Wow hey shut your mouth shut medicine
[ __ ] but out here
if you're with us earlier we recorded
some of these guys playing yesterday
phil mickelson told him that to iron is
for the ultimate spiel told me hit it
hard he's gonna run away past a plague
oh yeah that's a great touch oh that's a
good touch partner just see if he'll
give it to us oh man let me see if I
knew 2001 a little better all right
do it do it a - yes cuz that's how we
roll a social distancing fist bump is
good shot we would score low then the
best ball versus a go quarterback it's a
big difference looks like he's done it
that's a good strike yeah I could call
Justin good tee shot Tom Brady that'll
open the door for them now
baby uh yeah might be there they don't
make Manning no wasting any time
for the half unforced error that's a
game of checking can't wait to watch
this perfect timing it's on a pretty
good line good good yes sir is it ever
Wow if one of these guys can hit a good
tee shot here and get it in the fairway
be huge - very attractive right get one
of the pros to hit the second shot in
the alternate-shot format
[Laughter]
yeah I get shot okay for you yep it's
perfect because that gives us the widest
fairway and you just gave me a good
angle up the green okay great shot he'll
have a look at that green